good evening and welcome to the
one-millionth Academy Award we are not
your hosts but we're gonna stand here a
little too long so that the people who
get us a today tomorrow will think that
we hosted
that's great that's great so just a
quick update for everybody in case
you're confused there is no host tonight
there won't be a popular movie category
and Mexico is not paying for the wall
[Applause]
and we won't be doing awards during the
commercials but we will be presenting
commercials during the awards so if all
the winners could please say Hellmann's
mayonnaise we're on the side of food
instead of your speeches that would be
great again we are not your host this
year but if we had hosted it probably
would have gone like this I'm Freddie
Mercury well I'm a wife Buster scrubs I
hardly know her hey check that's a good
one
hey chadwick boseman what kind of plans
you got later these banks are so tight
they've entered my spider-verse
I'm Sam Elliott for Sam Elliott mustache
wax rolls on Netflix what's next my
microwave makes a movie
and don't worry Bradley after four kids
I too have peed myself at the Grammys
cheese sandwiches from the fire fence
away
we're not gonna do any of that no but to
me any of that we are here to present
the Award for Outstanding Supporting
Actress although in my experience all
actresses are outstanding supporting
actress is because women naturally
support each other for example
[Applause]
- for example I support both of you
financially yes and I hold your boobs
while you jog and Tina I double your
dialogue internationally it's always a
bit of that of less than baby the
nominees for outstanding supporting
actress Amy Adams vice Evita Regina Kane
is Beale Street Patrol Emma Stone the
favorite Rachel Weisz the favorite
and the Oscar goes to Regina
this is the first Oscar and nomination
for Regina king
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
um to be standing here representing one
of the greatest artists of our time
James Baldwin this it's a little surreal
James Baldwin burst this baby and Barry
you nurtured her you surrounded her with
so much love and support so it's
appropriate for me to be standing here
because I'm an example of what it looks
like when support and love is poured
into someone mom don't love you so much
thank you
for teaching me that God is always
leaning always has been leaning in my
direction
gheh Moses there asked me about that
later
um so many people to think Chelsea
Barnard who brought this project to
Annapurna Megan Ellison Annapurna Plan B
this amazing cast my sisters in art
marina Amy mmm
Emma Rachel has been an honor to have my
name
he just said with yours this whole step
of the way
it's been pretty amazing the rivers
family Kiki
Coleman Tiana's Stefan Oh
god is good all the time
[Applause]